you're not making as much money as you
want to make because you're not getting
as many leads as you need to have to
sell stuff to and you're probably not
getting as many leads as you need
because you're not giving away enough
free stuff because fundamentally if you
give something away for free you will
almost always have demand for it and if
it's good you'll have exponential demand
for because the value equation gets
broken when you give away free stuff the
value equation has four variables the
dream outcome which is what somebody
wants the perceived lik of achievement
which is if I buy the thing How likely
is it that I get the result that I want
you have the time delay between when I
buy and when I get so if I have to lose
weight and it takes 12 months versus 12
days it's going to be way more valuable
for me to buy something it takes 12 days
and then there's effort and sacrifice
which is how much work am I going to
have to do and how much stuff am I going
to have to stop doing that I like doing
as a result of doing this purchase if I
don't have to do anything it's
guaranteed it's immediate you have an
incredibly valuable thing if you make it
for free then you get insane demand
which then we translate into leads